hard work will not make you rich I get
driven nuts by the amount of gurus and
influencers and whatever who want to
brag and say no one can outwork me I'm
the best in the world so many people
outwork me I still make more money than
them there has to be something else one
of the things that grinds my gears about
a lot of people that I see on Instagram
that you probably see too is this whole
like no one can outwork me Mantra first
off it's objectively false because many
people a outwork you today be outward
give in the past see you haven't met
everyone indeed it doesn't [ __ ]
matter anyways it's the same thing when
someone's like I'm the best and you have
to say you're the best because if you
don't think you're the best it shows
that you're not confident to me I don't
take that at all if someone's like I'm
the best then why aren't you on [ __ ]
Billboards that's what the best would
look like absolutely you need to do the
work you need to put volume in it's the
only way you get better but if you start
claiming that you are the best you
cannot be outworked you are making
statements that you know are not true
why are we bragging about work because
work has very little to do with the
highest levels of the game Warren
Buffett talks about if he makes two good
decisions a year he's had a good year
and so how how is it that one of the
best investors one of the best business
people in terms of measuring it by money
which is how you measure business talks
about how he does basically nothing
reads five or six hours a day eats
McDonald's and makes a couple good
decisions a year how is it that that guy
is making so much more money than the
people who are bragging about the fact
that they work so hard everyone only has
the same hours of the day anybody who
only sleeps eight hours or only sleeps
seven hours and works the remaining of
hours of the day all of them would be
tied for hardest working so what creates
output you have volume of activity and
then you have the leverage of the
activity that you're doing that's what
creates the total output in order to do
anything you must do something there has
to be some level of energy that gets
input into the system our activity in
terms of number of activities is a very
newbie measure of success in the
beginning Warren Buffett doesn't say
I sent a thousand emails today he
doesn't talk like that he's playing a
different game Jeff Bezos didn't like
woke up at 4am today now mind you I'm
saying this to somebody who likes waking
up early we can't be as superstitious
about what matters waking up early
doesn't matter going to bed late doesn't
matter not sleeping a lot doesn't matter
the few things that matter are the
inputs that go into the system that have
the most leverage to create the most
output now if you're a newbie and you
can't get your ass off the couch then by
all means figure out how to actually get
your ass off the couch and do stuff but
then there's only so many hours and so
boom and then very quickly you hit your
capacity of work great you've maximized
that now what the leverage that we have
on that activity is going to dictate how
much we get out of it and if we do a low
leverage activity many many many times
we might get more than a high leverage
activity that gets done once a CEO who's
going to work with acquisition.com Works
virtually every hour of every day when
they come in almost everybody does
sometimes they ask they're like am I
going to be working more or like it's
impossible for you to work more but you
are going to be changing what you work
on because that's the only lever we have
there's only 24 hours so we're going to
switch these nine out and we're going to
plop these in with higher leverage
activities and so the way that we do
that is we look at their calendars and
we look at their org chart this is how
you [ __ ] grow business you look at
what they spend their time on and you
see which of these activities are low
Leverage is there anyone else in this
org chart that we can hand these
activities to and if a large percentage
of these activities are a certain type
of thing and they don't exist in their
chart then it's a role that we need to
hire the point of why I hate the concept
of no one cannot work me is that there
are many ways to win the game if you
were to think about an amazing goal as a
dragon to be slain if you are familiar
with video games in any way when you
create like a war party you have a group
of people that are going to go go on a
quest you don't just have 10 paladins or
guys who just have Shields and swords so
you've got a Healer a mage that's really
good at damage but can't take a lot of
damage then you've got a paladin you
can't hit as hard but he can take a lot
of shots you find people who have
complementary skills if you're playing
football you don't have 10 running backs
the entrepreneur really should be the
coach of the team it's about organizing
the pieces and how the well they play
together that ultimately determines how
good the team is like how many times
have you seen the team with the All-Star
that has the poor Supporting Cast get
beat by the overall better team it
happens all the time a lot of
entrepreneurs as I see in them are
trying to play the game like they're the
star player and they want to score all
the points but they lose to Apple
because Apple's got a team we celebrate
a specific action like work when it's
really just saying oh look there's a
paladin who can take a lot of hits cool
that's not the only thing that's
required to win I think what is more
valuable is to know what are each of the
roles that exists within the business a
b is there one of these that you map to
based on your characteristics and skill
sets and then see what is my eventual
Evolution through entrepreneurship we'll
start at the beginning which is what are
the players on the field so if you think
about it by function you've got somebody
who has to promote who's got to be a
good marketer they have to understand
how to make things known across
different platforms telling stories
building a brand providing value to an
audience that's what marketing is sales
is being able to convert that raw
attention into a sale direct response
ads sales Pages video your sales letters
Etc which is pretty much anything that's
physical products or software based
that's low ticket or it's higher ticket
people-to-people hand-in-hand combat who
know how to in the beginning sell and
then later train how to sell and then
later later lead people who train how to
sell these are not necessarily the same
people I've met really brilliant
marketers who suck at sales I'm really
good sales people sucking marketing then
you've got somebody who understands
product how do I make something
beautiful the guy who started Shopify
he's not CEO of Shopify he's had a
product he's a mage he knows how to cast
spells and you've got the experienced
people who are managing everything
outside of the actual product itself how
do customers engage with us how it can
provide more value how to give an
amazing experience how do we make sure
they're hitting these Milestones this
person who knows customers experience
and customer success is not the same
person who understands product and ux
and design that's a different game which
is different the guy who knows how to
close this different guy that knows how
to promote the bigger the Enterprise
gets the more specialized the skill
becomes and the deeper The Well of
experience that people need to be they
have to be more specialized when people
are like I can't be outworked you're
bragging about the wrong thing it should
be like I can't be out recruited I can't
be outmanaged no one can build a culture
like me that's super high leverage
across the organization no one can lead
like me but no one can outwork me
it's just an irrelevant activity metric
I love working I work all the time but I
would never claim that no one works
harder than me I tend to have very good
leverage with the activities that I do I
spend tons of time writing a book in
that book prints and sells copies
forever it's a different way to play the
game and so level two of this which
player you are in the Middle Run of this
you end up segregating yourself to a
portion of the business that you're an
expert at or that you're best at CMO or
chief sales officer Chief product
officer it's not about one player being
the champion here it's about how the
team works together which then gets to
the third level of this is just about
being the coach think about what the
best coaches do they're literally trying
to head hunt the best players and
they're trying to recruit the best
people from college look at what Google
does think about their recruiting
efforts they have huge influxes
dedicated to getting the best and
smartest people out of college and they
have another ring for the best and
smartest people come out of business
school and then another one is their
very high level recruiting at the top of
the executive level the parallels
between sports and business they are
almost the same in that way now mind you
you can only have you know 10 or 11
people on the field you might have ten
thousand but if each of those players
represents a a function or Department of
the business it makes more sense when we
move up the levels of Entrepreneurship
we need to make sure that we're playing
the right game and that we're using the
right metric to measure our success
final level of this is being the coach
is recruiting the top level Executives
and creating a farm system underneath to
feed into the company that you have so
you can have a sustained competitive
advantage and create a dynasty for the
team so you can create the best winning
team every year and have the soft skills
of creating culture of high performance
so that you get the most out of every
individual player and the difference
between amazing coaching and mediocre or
poor coaching is what would players do
if they had no coach or leader and then
what would they do if they had the best
coach and best leader the Delta between
those two is the value of the coach the
value of the CEO the CEO needs to have
the highest return on time out of anyone
in the organization because they need to
always be solving the next problem as
long as when they replace their time the
activities they do with the new stuff
builds the business even more then that
trade will always work and if CEO can
come in and turn a business around even
behemoths around in two three years
based on the standards that they set and
the values that they stand for that
Delta across the entire organization is
your greatest Leverage